رئيس الوزراء ، أود أن أسألك هذا ،
فأنت تحذر الأمم المتحدة
بشدة من أن السودان على شفا حرب أهلية واسعة النطاق سمعناها اليوم بشكل مروع 87
جثة تم العثور عليها في مقبرة جماعية في ويستار لمدة أسبوع طويل
هنا في أعمال عنف جنسي وعرقي ،
هل تعتقد أن السودان على
شفا حرب
أهلية ، فهذا وضع خطير للغاية يمكن أن يزيل التصعيد إلى عواقب كما ذكرت الحرب الأهلية المختلفة.
عنصر واحد فيزا مع
الآخر لذلك كانت المخاطر موجودة في
جميع الأوقات وستتصاعد بالتأكيد
مع تدهور الوضع وعلينا جميعًا
أن نتجنب ذلك وأعتقد أن هذا هو السبب في أنه
من المهم أن المجتمع الدولي
أن
الجيران الإقليميين ، الثلاثي
الرباعي ، يجب أن يتحدث مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة
بنفس
الصوت جميعًا على
أهمية وقف
الأعمال العدائية والتطلعات
الحكومية لاستعادة هذه التطلعات.